john dunco from 90 university
talking about speed ups okay
let's hear it so so thank you very much
barbara and and uh
first of all i'm deeply grateful to the
organizers for
giving a chance to participate at all
and especially to talk to you guys about
this problem so the topic is um quantum
speed ups with smaller quantum computers
and this is sort of a bit of a strange
question that we've been thinking about
for a little while cooking at low heat
starting while i was still at max planck
with ignacio sirac in 2018
and we still have little results
dripping that i'll tell you about
in a second so
so uh we started with a basic
motivational question and it's like
suppose you're given a computational
problem and let's recruit concreteness
say uh
satisfiability problems you're given a
boolean formula over n variables
and you have a quantum computer which
can only handle k qubits and where k is
you know significantly smaller than n
so we wanted to know like does it really
help to use the chrono computer at all
is it any good
so here i i don't want to you know to
get you on the wrong track thinking
about
sat and computing just yet uh let's
assume that quantum computers are really
good at sat
but still it's not clear whether it's
going to help so on one hand the
intuition says it should right if it's a
faster device even though it's smaller
you should be able to use it
but if you for instance think about
factoring and i give you
like a challenge to factor 1024 digit
number
and and you have a device which can do
this in one step but when the number is
bounded by 128 digits it's not really
clear
this will help you at all in any
significant way so so this was
sort of our basic question and i somehow
don't want to go too much into the
motivation for this question
i would feel like i'm preaching to the
choir uh at this conference but of
course
you know we're all trying to get around
uh limitations of real-world devices
which will be available in next few
years
and here uh today's talk uh a small
disclaimer is
compared in comparison to other talks
that we've heard gonna be a little bit
in la la land
uh in the sense that i will not be
considering any errors and my algorithms
are in fact gonna be quite deep and i
will not be thinking about that
i will just be focusing on size issues
and my starting point in fact will not
be
uh whether i can get a device to do
something useful i will be assuming that
i have a device which can at least for
some instant sizes beat
classical performances and moreover i
will not necessarily
think about supremacy type statements
but just speed ups maybe quadratic speed
up strangers for interesting problems
so let's stick with basic curiosity
curiosity about the first question that
i posited
so how would you handle this question
what to do with a case size quantum
computer given an enzymes problem
so like three things you can you can do
you can somehow hack it you can simply
look at
a popular algorithm for your problem and
you can see whether there are any small
subroutines which are just the right
size for your chrono computer and then
speed those up
and in practice this is probably the way
you would do it and probably the best
way to actually get a best world real
will speed up
or you could try to be a little bit more
systematic
for instance you could come up with a
quantum algorithm for your problem then
look at the quantum
circuit and then somehow partition into
smaller sizes and maybe use a large
classical computation to help you out
when you're lacking qubits and this was
done in a series of works by
bravi and smith and swollen already in
2016 and pangatal
more recently and in here we're going to
be doing something similar
but on the side of classical algorithms
you're going to start with a classical
algorithm which somehow chops well
and then and then when the instance
becomes small enough you're going to
quantum enhance those um and there will
of course be trade-offs in which method
would be the best for a particular case
but i will focus only on this third
third part here
so the setting in more detail i will
have some classical algorithm in mind
for some particular problem
specifically i'll be thinking about
boolean satisfiability and
the algorithms of shining would be a z
dpl if these names don't mean anything
to it doesn't really matter i'll
introduce whatever i will need at a
later point
i will also be thinking about
hamiltonian cycles problems in the
algorithm of epstein
i will assume that i have a at least in
principle a quantum algorithm that does
better than those classical algorithms
for the problems at hand here i will
have a few options
i will assume i have an n size instance
the size here
the best thing is to think about boolean
satisfiability and the size of the
problem is sort of the solution space
size
which is the number of variables i'm
working with my quantum computer is
smaller
and at this point i want to ask so when
does the quantum computer genuinely help
and and here here i have to make start
making some choices and then
the choice we made was we're interested
going to be interested in polynomial
speedups
and in this standard asymptotic sense uh
you know in a complexity theoretical
sense
so for these types of problems these uh
problems for np-hard problems
uh the exact randoms are typically
exponential and they can be written in
the in the form of you know
two to the gamma n where this gamma is
some pre-factor
sort of determining the actual speed of
my algorithm
and and what i'm interested in starting
with an algorithm which has some gamma c
constant which is dictated by the
classical algorithm and then reducing it
by some constant value
and this is immediately a polynomial
speed up over the original algorithm
uh and off the bat you can notice that
that this imposes some restrictions and
reasonable
questions like for instance case
certainly cannot be constant recall k is
the size of my chrono computer
uh because if it's constant then i can
simulate it in constant time
right and logarithmic is not not going
to be good enough so the most
interesting cases are where k is
actually proportional to n but smaller
so i'm going to introduce a constant
alpha which tells me just
how much smaller my quantum computer
than it is than the classical but both
will scale in in the setting that i'm
considering
so the method that we propose is uh
something we call a hybrid divide and
conquer
uh it comes from the the observation
that there are classical algorithms that
naturally fall into smaller
smaller parts like algorithms which
which employ divide and conquer
strategies
or algorithms which are recursive or
so-called back checking algorithms
also to have this feature that within
the run you're somehow simplifying the
problem and running it in a smaller
instance
and please always have in mind the
picture of you know the problem solving
boolean satisfiability problems
where i have uh uh clauses which
constrain uh the possible settings of
let's say three bits in threesat
um in a weak sense so a seven out of
eight
uh configurations are gonna be fine but
i still have many many conditions that i
have to
satisfy simultaneously and in this case
for instance backtracking algorithms uh
would generate something
that i'm gonna call search trees so
they're gonna be trees which
where each vertex denotes a partial
assignment
right so it's a it's a proposed
assignment and when i set the next
variable i branch i bifurcate into the
next two possible nodes in my graph
so this is exactly what it is in the
case of backtracking algorithms
but i can also think a little bit more
generally these nodes could be
more general objects like like sub calls
to some subroutines of my algorithm
might utilize so this is what i mean
when i say a tree
so the hybrid method is going to be you
know as straightforward as can be
you pick your classical and quantum
algorithm you run the classical
algorithm until your problem shrinks
enough and when it's small enough to be
fit in your quantum computer
you run the quantum computer and that's
it right so that
it's it's really not very deep at this
level at all
um the classical algorithm tells me how
i split the thing
uh the quantum computer can run
whichever algorithm you wish they can be
completely
distinct algorithms or in principle the
quantum computer could run a quantum
enhanced version of the classical
algorithm
and then i'm interested in expressing
the complexity of the overall process
that this hybrid method is a function of
k and n which are the sizes of the
quantum and classical machine
sort of the instance in the quantum
machine and the corresponding
complexities of the classical
a and quantum algorithm b and of course
the catch is going to be that you you
will fail to get asymptotic speed ups uh
for for a number of
not completely uh maybe of the bat
obvious reasons
um i would like to talk more about
quantum algorithms np problems uh
because if you think it's a very
interesting topic you know
i don't really have the time for it but
let's just say the following
uh we don't believe quantum computers
can solve np-hard problems in polynomial
time
but they can still help a lot so we can
essentially quadratically speed up most
worst case algorithms
we have interesting suggestions for
approximation algorithms that we heard
about
in the talk before and we'll hear again
quantum computers may offer interesting
heuristics
so algorithms for which we don't have
with promise good guarantees in a
theoretical sense
but maybe practice will show that that
for important instances they work well
and what i want to point out that
generically
quantum computers either help in the
sense of being an enhancer of a
classical algorithm
or provide a genuinely new approach and
i want to think about enhancers right
because then whatever the classical
community has figured out about
classical heuristics
i sort of can import that knowledge into
the quantum domain and not necessarily
have to do as many
numerical tests as you might want to do
so how would this work ideally to give
you a little bit of a flavor
so suppose we're going to solve boolean
satisfiability in the most naive
possible way
so i'm going to do a brute force search
so i'm going to choose each variable and
my tree is going to branch into the
situation where i chose it to be 0 or 1.
so that's my classical algorithm my
quantum algorithm is the
quantum analog of brute force search is
going to be grover search
and in this case my tree is really going
to be a full tree
complexities are simple in the classical
case it's just 2 to the n
so my gamma rate for the classical
algorithm is 1 and the quantum means 2
to the n half because i get a quadratic
speed up
and if you do very simple math you see
that the hybrid runtime
picks up a nice format in which you you
get put to the exponent which somehow
smoothly interpolates
between the classical runtime and the
quantum runtime
with the corresponding weight which is
determined by the ratio of the
uh classical computer size is instant
size and the quantum computer size
so this is of course for boot for search
but you can show that holds more
generally for algorithms which
somehow come from whose runtimes come
from standard recurrence relations
and you always get this nice shape that
the hybrid runtime
is governed by a quantity which is
somehow interpolating smoothly between
the classical and quantum runtime
okay it doesn't work always of course i
will show that generically actually
fails for some reasons
but what i want to point out now is that
at least in this picture
uh this gamma hybrid value which tells
me about the speed of the hybrid
approach
is always always better than the
classical one
no matter how small my alpha was so no
matter how small my chrono computer is
relative to the instant size i always
win a little bit a small polynomial
improvement
and when this happens we call this a
threshold-free scenario
so we're kind of interested when is this
ever possible and just going back a
little bit towards why would
why would you care because this allows
you a free control of trade-off between
the problem sizes you want to handle and
the amount of speed up
you actually want to attain
and and it can fail for essentially two
different ways the reasons one is
because your algorithms require too much
space
specifically the quantum algorithms in
which case you get no real speed up i
will say what i mean by this in a second
or because your search trees are are of
inappropriate shape and in the second
case you will only get speed ups when
your alphas are really high
so it's not a threshold free setting so
let's look at this for a second
so in the case of problem with
computational size
the is that i pulled a small slide of
hand in my computation of this
expression here which talks about the
speed in terms of interpolation between
classical and quantum runtime
in that i said that i start my chrono
computer when the instance becomes of
size k
so k would be alpha times n that's
that's what this equation essentially
says
but note that k is really the size of
the formula i can handle
in the boolean satisfactory example but
the size of the quantum computer is
generically larger than that
right it is it is governed by the
quantity which is the space complexity
of my quantum algorithm
and in the simplest terms if it's f of n
the space complexity then then the
size of the formula i can handle given a
quantum computer of size alpha n
is f inverse alpha n not alpha n
so for instance if my uh space
complexity is n squared
then the effective size i can handle is
square root alpha n
both alpha and n not just alpha and if i
do the math with this i see that my
coefficient with the quantum
term in my speed actually starts
decaying as my instance grows
so it's not a polynomial speed up in the
limit it's it's super linear but but not
a polynomial speed
not what i want so this says that the
space complexity of my quantum algorithm
should be essentially linear
and that's a very very stringent
constraint
to give an example of how bad trees come
into play
we'll see this more later on but you
know classical algorithms
do better than just brute for search and
at some points for instance they can
figure out that certain variables have
to be fixed to some particular value
and then a child and then a parent has
only one child right and
the algorithm is from that point one
much more efficient maybe linear maybe
polynomial in time
so if i can only switch on my chrono
computer later on in the game when my
problem has become very simple
it actually has no hard work to do i i'm
using it in the regime whether when the
runtime that remains is still is just
polynomial
and the hard work was already done by
the classical device
this yields no speed up in the end but
if my threshold is
uh higher like if my quantum computer is
comparatively larger then i can get it
to use
sort of to be active in this this
exponentially hard regime
so when does it work it's actually quite
easy to characterize this in
a very very broad sense by using
something called a tree search search
for the composition and uh
credit to matisse tranella who kind of
pointed out that this is a nice way to
represent it
so once i fix a classical algorithm a i
have some
search tree defined and together with a
quantum algorithm b and a size limit
alpha n
i can somehow figure out in my search
tree when will i be able to switch on my
quantum device
so we'll get a search for t sub zero the
blue region where where i have to use
the classical device
and i will have a bunch of subtrees
dangling at the leaves of the
t sub naught where i can use the quantum
device i'm going to call this trees t
sub j
and then it's not difficult to convince
yourself that if the following is true
then then i can get a speed up so
um i'm going to assume that the entire
tree is is exponential in size i can
relax this but i don't want to
um and and the hybrid approach will
achieve a polynomial speed up if the
following two conditions are met
if the average time taken by the
classical algorithm on these substitutes
t sub j
is polynomially smaller than the average
time of the quantum algorithm
and second if the if a constant fraction
of these substitution subjects
itself exponentially size and the
intuition should be very clear so i i'm
insisting on exponential trees because
then i don't have to care about
overheads and fine grain complexities
um and conditions one and two well one
tells me that the quantum computer
should actually be faster once i use it
and condition two guarantees that
quantum computer will still do some of
the hard lifting
and both conditions one and two can be
contingent on what alpha is
and if the family of trees is such that
it's not then it's a threshold fish
scenario and we have
a couple of versions of this theorem but
this is sort of the most general one
so now uh this was all not particularly
deep but but maybe
illustrative i want to tell you about
what we figure out when it actually does
work
so these are going to be a sequence of
examples where we could make the quantum
algorithms
sufficiently space efficient without
sacrificing speed while maintaining
reversibility
so that's actually achieving this
reversibility and the very first example
was in the first paper that we did
we tried to quantize schoning's
algorithm for set solving
it doesn't matter how it works because
we failed
there was a problem with that but then
we figured out that there's a
de-randomized version of the same
algorithm
which reduces the problem of
satisfiability to another problem which
is called promisable sat
so there uh you're interested in the
following question i give you a formula
and a satisfying as an assignment
of all the variables and i ask you
whether there exists a satisfying
assignment
within l distance uh from from your
starting point
from your assignment x so l distance
with respect to the hamming distance
that means
you're allowed to flip as many as l bits
from the starting assignment
and now the the random is showing
somehow splits the search space into
these balls
and then runs promise both sat on each
one of them and if you solve this
promise both set naively you get a
ternary search tree
because you you what you do is you check
each clause and
which is not satisfied and then you know
that if you flip one of the three bits
it will become satisfied but you don't
know which one
so you somehow try all three right and
this this yields your tree
but for us this yields a problem uh
because note that in the end i have to
somehow always keep and keep an eye on
which variables have
flipped all along and since i have l
variables that can clip and a
flip and l is somehow proportional to n
and since i need to store the indices of
the the variables and i have
n variables so i need log n bits for
that this is n log n
and and this actually constitutes too
much space
i need something which is linear so it
doesn't work
but then you can resolve this by noting
that in fact what we do we don't really
care about lists we don't care about
storing sequentially which variables
we've split we just we need to know
which ones there were
so i need to store sets not lists and
says require
less space so in fact i can do that in k
times log n divided by k
and when n and k are sort of
proportional then this is really
essentially linear but then you come
into other problems that the set object
is not reversible
if i add a variable to a set at the next
step i no longer know which variable
i've added
and that's somehow bad for quantum
computing
um and if you do direct
reversibilization of the process then
you get something which is exponentially
slow
but then we came up with a recursive
memory structure i can tell you later on
about it in questions if you if you
would like to see it
which achieves the right space space
complexity and has fully time updates
and queries and everything you would
like with the lists
and somehow taking that further we've
shown that you can also do similar
things for
different types of algorithms
specifically for epson's algorithm for
hamilton cycles and cubic graphs
again i don't need to really go into
details this is the part of the story
where it becomes
depending on your preference other very
delicate because you'll be very careful
with your space all along and you know
really read the details of the algorithm
kick out everything you don't need
you can call it tedious depending on
your flavor but but the point is it does
work
and what we get is a polynomial speed up
no matter what alpha is no matter how
small my quantum computer is relative
the instance
uh relative to the best known classical
bound and the speed up is threshold free
for all alphas
and essentially i get to use grover
search because the trees are
effectively close enough to fall to win
but this is not always the case right so
now i'm gonna take you into the research
that is not
fully finished but we know some results
they can share with you which has to do
with backtracking
uh so in in backtracking as i briefly
described
you're somehow looking at the formula
and you're choosing a variable and
you're trying to figure out whether you
know how to set the value of that
particular value and this is generating
a sort of a tree of partial assignments
where where when a node has two children
that means i didn't know how to set it
so i guessed
and when it has one child then there was
something telling me that it should be
one value or the other
so the size of the tree depends on sort
of these local
reasoning rules you're using to decide
whether you can set a value
and this yields different algorithms for
instance the so-called dpl algorithm
which is very famous a very famous
heuristic for set solving
uses two simple rules like checking
whether the variable is just a single
variable in a clause then you know how
to set it
or whether it appears with the same
polarity in every clause then you again
know how to set it
in the so-called ppse algorithm i'll say
something more about it in a second
uses something which is called s
implication which essentially looks for
polynomially provable statements that
that a particular value should be
zero or one uh in this case you can't
use group search anymore
so the trees can be sparse enough that
the number of vertices is uh
less than the square root of the full
tree and the grover search algorithm
somehow will always explore the full
tree no matter what there's no way to
make
you know uh to stop searching in one
probabilistic range
luckily uh ashley montanaro and
unbinarist and collaborators they've
come up with a quantum back tracking
scheme algorithm which is based on
random walks which
for large instances really achieves a
quadratic speed up in the number of
nodes you will explore relative to the
classical classical algorithm
you don't really i mean you do
everything in superposition so it's not
about nodes but it's quadratically
faster
in terms of the nodes so now i'm
interested in using quantum backtracking
if i can um it turns out you can
and it turns out that this uh allows you
to
quadratically to speed up to get
polynomial speed ups for for a
broad abstract family of search trees
and these are those
which are somehow everywhere dense
enough so i'm going to say that a tree
is sort of lambda dense
if every subtree of depth larger than a
cup ion is exponentially sized
i don't care about the exponent it's
some lambda it doesn't matter what it is
for the moment
now now if these trees are generated by
an algorithm
uh then in principle of course i can run
backtracking over it
and if it's the case that that logical
reasoning which which dictates the shape
of the tree i can do space efficiently
then the entire thing can be done faster
using a hybrid approach
so i'm somehow satisfying both
conditions of the main theorem by
enforcing
the tree is dense enough and i will not
go too much into detail but from this
you can do a leap to a
different kind of reasoning that you
know if my problem is hard enough i
really don't have to be clever at all
so under the strong exponential time
hypothesis i will know that there exists
a sat family
where the trees are going to be
guaranteed to be as dense as i wish
and then i can always get a polynomial
speed up well over
any classical algorithm in fact of
course it's if you believe in the
stronger exponential time hypothesis
uh we can discuss later with what that
means if if you're unfamiliar with the
time
um by the way uh there's this lambda
parameter which is the density
this is also telling me whether i can
use grover search or whether i need to
do backtracking
if it's larger than one half grover will
do if it's below i'm gonna use quantum
back tracking and there's no reason why
i wouldn't
now the fourth class is sort of a
painful class because i really wanted to
have a positive result here but
unfortunately we're not there yet
it's the algorithm of uh pathuri pulax
saxon
and this i like is because it's it's the
basis for the fastest known exact
sat solver at the moment it has some
bells and whistles on top of it but
essentially this is what you do
so in this algorithm the search tree is
built by making guesses
or by proving as simple implications an
s implication is
considering um sub formulas involving at
most
s clauses and then you check whether
this sub formula forces your variable to
be either zero or one
and this is a large polynomial
computation but it's polynomials it's
sort of a polynomial size proof
and the theorem ppse theorem tells you
that if you do this along the path which
leads to satisfying assignment if one
exists
you will not have to make too many
guesses you will have to do something
like .38
n guesses so the purple ones where i
bifurcate this is where i had to guess
the green ones
are the ones where i could prove the
value so we really wanted to speed this
up because then you would get a you know
a quantum speed up of the best
algorithm that we have but sadly doesn't
really work
because this suffers from bad trees like
the gases can happen early on and in
this case the quantum computer will
have nothing nothing to do and you could
beat this if you come up
with a very space space-efficient
implementation of sort of these logical
steps that the algorithm does
and we know how to do them only for some
special classes of formulas
and we kind of think that in general it
cannot be done sufficiently space
efficient because it would imply that
big complete problems can be done in
sub-linear space with sub-exponential
time
we kind of we're kind of skeptical this
can be achieved or rather we're
skeptical that we can achieve let's put
it this way
um okay so now i will close
essentially the talk with a little bit
of theory and some practice and the
theory is going to be very very shallow
but but i have to ask the question right
so so far everything i've shown
achieves a small polynomial speed up
over the over the classical algorithm
right so you can ask yourself
but can i even in principle do better
than that and i'll give you two very
very simple direct answers
uh one in the case that you're starting
a hybrid approach which is really using
the classical
sort of tree type process to reduce the
search size and then runs it on a chrono
computer
then generically you will not be able to
do better than polynomial faster
even if the quantum algorithm itself is
exponentially faster
simply because the top of the tree the
stuff that you run a classical device
has has known trivial depth and it's
generically exponentially large
right so you will get a you can get
better than quadratic speedups for
certain alphas etc
but generically not better than
polynomial
uh but can we do better than this and
the answer is
sort of yeah sure of course you would
like to use quantum computers also to
help you
in the top of the tree and then this is
something they would
like to do but in fact i can prove that
we can do exponential separations
um by constructing a contract well not a
contrived but a sort of an
obvious artificial example just just to
show that it can be done
so it's it's very simple so take you
know let's believe that that there
exists bqp decision problems that take
uh two to the exponential time in a
classical computer right and
in fact they're going to be sort of
decision problems over over over
circuits
that are promised to yield a zero or one
outcome with bounded away probability
from one half so under this assumption
for every alpha there exists a problem
family
such that the classical algorithm will
take the runtime 2 to the lambda alpha n
so alpha is this hypothetical rate of
simulating quantum computers
alpha is the size of my quantum computer
and n
is the size of the instance yet the
hybrid algorithm
does it in polynomial time and i mean
the algorithm is
so sorry the problem instance is sort of
in some sense it's the simplest one you
can imagine so imagine you have an
in-size
input and then you have a classical
circle which queries all bits of the
input
and based on this it constructs the
quantum circuit of size alpha n
and runs this many many times uh you
know iteratively doesn't
as long as everything is done
polynomially the quantum computer will
always be able to do
this in polynomial time combined with a
classical device
whereas the classical computer somehow
trivially always hits the
bottleneck that it has to compute what
this quantum circuit does
so it's a simple as can be um
now i i want to say that of course one
thing that we kind of care about in in
leiden and also myself personally i like
to time and again think about
you know practical aspects of all these
things so
right now we're investing in one
algorithm at a time and trying to figure
out whether we can get this polynomial
speedups
and this is interesting right and we
know that in principle it can be done
beyond just decision problems you can go
to branch and bound type problems and
it's
still most likely going to work but what
one one should really be worried about
and
thinking about is speeding up really you
know well-functioning classical
heuristics
right i will talk about this in a second
because you know we're solving epi-heart
problems and we're not going to be
running things for an exponential amount
of time
and then things become a little bit
tricky right then then theory starts to
break down
you can't say much about trees so we
have a couple of uh
one bachelor student in fact who's now
studying where the trees from dpl come
from
what do they look like in in the case of
hard random instances
and whether we can get sort of small
small very modest polynomial speed ups
uh but down the line all this is going
to be sort of still lacking because i'm
thinking
asymptotically which is not what i
really want to do
so what we really want to do in the real
world is somehow you know heuristically
combined classical with quantum
algorithms
um and we started something in that
direction
specifically where we're interested
whether we can detect whether a given
instance should be handled by classical
or a quantum algorithm
it was a similarly simple question i
gave you an instance of let's say
a max cut and i ask you whether a qr a
with some data will outperform gw
on that particular instance and you can
easily see that many that
under at least under the unique games
conjecture to assume that gw is the best
approximation algorithm
determining whether it does better or
not is itself
probably nv hard you can tweak the
question a little bit to make it then be
hard under the unique
games conjecture so we throw everything
into machine learning machinery
and it does quite well it predicts like
with 90 accuracy that things work
and we imagine using this as a
subroutine an algorithm which actually
chops up
our problem heuristically and of course
here we can absolutely forget about any
any theoretical statements one has to
resolve to uh numerics
um okay so let me give you just a few
final remarks uh
to type few sends so i mentioned that i
will
somehow defend one thinking about
np-hard algorithms
and i think the fully honest statement
is because they actually matter
right so so they're somehow shunned in
the quantum case because we're not going
to get our
exponential separation there but we need
to solve nap hard problems as well as we
can
right they're the commonplace in ai
they're all over the place and ai is
something very important nowadays
so we need to find ways of doing it
better using a quantum device
there's a second reason which is sort of
more local and pragmatic and that's
since we don't have really really smart
ways of solving np-hard problems
you know we don't have something which
doesn't nepali time um
we're not doing much better than search
and our local algorithms
can be relatively simple and because of
this we we can come up with quantum
algorithms which require less space
so it ends up working because of this
particular reason so we can somehow
leverage
the brute force against the you know the
clever algorithms because the clever
algorithms are not
so insanely uh deep like you're using
some very theoretical deep structures
and things would probably not work out
as well
now maybe you have a feeling that things
are somehow
not super optimistic for for small
quantum computers but
i just want to emphasize that we've made
a bunch of choices here to be able to
make clean statements like
caring about asymptotics and things that
you can prove this is of course not
something you will necessarily care
about in the next five to ten years
um our definition of what it means to be
a smaller quantum computer is sort of
as stringent as possible because we're
talking about the instant size
we could have been thinking about the
same question but when
we demand the quantum computer to be
sort of proportional to the smallest
known space complexity for the same
algorithm
you can define it that way in this case
most of our problems with size would
sort of disappear
but down the line i feel that there's
still if there's interest
it's a weird question so well well
thinking about it
there's still a gap between the present
and model and then what really matters
in reality so we would like to do some
fine grain analysis
and actually do this properly using
numerical tests
and things like this um so yeah
that's that's about it i would like to
thank you for for for listening uh for
for this to this talk and all my
collaborators who contributed
to various parts of the stuff that i've
been talking about and a little bit of
advertisement if you want to find out
more about what we're doing in the
netherlands here
at least in in around leiden and
delft and amsterdam you can visit these
links here
and uh i'm super happy to take whatever
questions might have popped up that i
absolutely did not pay attention to
i have to say okay pedro
thank you for your talk clap a little
bit of course
maybe i'm the only one with their mic on
anyhow so are there some questions right
now
i have a very tiny question uh in in one
of your examples you introduced
something which you referred to as a
cubic graph what is a cubic graph
apologist degree so i would call it a
ternary graph maybe but okay i
understand well
it's actually the title of the paper
uh-huh
paper is called you know finding on
cubic graphs so you use that term but
but but yeah
the degree that ternary graphs sure yeah
okay
okay does anybody else want to pose a
question maybe one of the panelists
[Music]
maybe not
okay this is also okay so because we are
running a little bit late
so well many thanks for the for the
opportunity and
i know the talk was a little bit fast
please if you found anything interesting
feel free to email me at any point about
anything i'll be super happy to talk
about this
yes thanks vadon yeah that's good i
think it's often it's hard to
if you talk for 30 minutes and you want
to cover some ground it's or to
go very slow so um okay so we will take
a little break
and um my watch my watch is not running
the same time as my computer
so it's um 37 so i guess
five minutes and then we'll start again